I'm Tyler Cowan professor of Economics
at George Mason University faculty
director of the mercus center I have a
podcast conversations with Tyler and I
co-founded a Blog marginal Revolution
and I'm the founder of emergent Ventures
emergent Ventures is an attempt to
deburau critize philanthropy but now
with over 400 winners uh it has quite a
reputation you know he Fellowship yes it
does that for you in a different way so
we're one of the set of emerging
institutions that certifies without
using higher education per se I think of
emerging Ventures as part of a parallel
networking system allowing everyone to
learn from each other yes 2018 that's
right at the end of the year uh Timothy
milanov was our very first winner
supporting typically Teena they're
teenagers when we start funding them now
some are in their early 20s
uh in the biomedical area that's where
I'm seeing the greatest most
concentrated cluster of talent we have
two meetups a year so there's an India
Meetup which is mostly the India winners
and then some other foreign winners who
cannot get a US Visa and then we have a
North American Meetup typically in
Northern Virginia it's become a little
complicated who goes to which Meetup
because we now have numbers that exceed
the sizes of our hotels but everyone
gets to go to some number of meetups you
and Alex ch rock at marginal Revolution
have been working on online education or
muks we call it marginal Revolution
University it's named after our blog so
it is online YouTube videos for
economics education mostly 5 to seven
minutes long where we cover everything
that would be in a major textbook it is
all free I love economics I began
studying economics when I was 13 and I
haven't stopped yet and most people
aren't ready for this new world where
you can just build projects and if you
out there can be ready for this world uh
by all means take advantage of it uh
asking us for support is one thing you
could do but whether or not that's a
good fit I mean my goodness just do
something you're born into this time
with these remarkable opportunities
please don't pass them by ask yourself
the honest question how do I fit into
this and try to do the very best you can
thank everyone for listening